now there he is life expectancy before I
tell you anything about it I just want
you to look at this graph with me and
remove it about in a second and I just
want you to I'm going to do it a couple
of times I just want you to look and ask
yourself two questions
two questions I've actually discussions
before number one when you notice what
do you notice when I move things around
change what you can see and what do you
wonder what can you observe what do you
notice about it and what questions does
this raise for you okay so if we just
have a look you can see at the moment
it's set at 1950 which is where this
data for use and if I just scroll a
little bit yoga behaviors oh yes okay so
now we're up to where the Bible's bought
in computers me so you can see not just
the graph is changing but you might also
notice these numbers down here are also
changing let me take it back to see this
do you see the numbers of changes on so
the whole thing is dynamic okay so bring
back like if there he is 1985 which
could be leans pretty close to halfway
and let's try and read the little
question should the president
okay so here we go a little bit of is
see how everything is changing your pain
now this is the most current data that
we have okay so remember I asked you two
questions the questions to add number
one what do you notice what can you
observe just by looking through that and
secondly what do you want us so there's
an awl or point out what's something
that they go to about the data just
right in the face what do you say today
nothing great Nick what is it what do
you say say yeah decreasing which is a
good thing right
so life expectancy over the last fifty
four years has been getting better and
it's getting better across the board you
might notice comparisons with other
countries as well and even though not
everyone is increasing at the same rate
everybody's decreasing
good thank you something else that
anyone else's loose again ah okay so she
is the fertility rate order birth weight
okay let me just go all the way back
look at I don't have before look at what
it is here by the way I think this is a
bit up to date data um why don't we have
twenty seventy dollars another one we
don't have twenty seventeen like it's
not finished yet no but you were at 2016
that's finished so this data takes a
long time to collect put together we'll
talk about how we take all that
information and send it's nothing like
this trolling but you can see at the
moment royal most recently this is what
these until any rate is let me just
bring that back and then I want you to
watch Chuck that number again you watch
that number let's go back to 1960 is a
significant jump let me take it back
okay we'll be sorry okay
he's throwing it down okay now watch
watching watch what happens to the
fertility rate for the last rule you ER
last for ten years
come that's interesting if you go back a
little further not a huge amount of
change still this is going back you know
twenty potties yeah watch what's the
number what's the number still about the
same still steady and then then look at
that what's going on here what was
happening in here have a look at the
time have a lot of what's happening
think so [ __ ] I heard someone say baby
boomers okay I don't hear we're going to
tell you wait is this a bunch clusters
we're talking about well you cannot
avoid when you're talking about
situations you can't avoid the
mathematics in a situation nor can you
avoid when you're to metamathematics of
it the social aspects of the situation
okay
now my code to baby boomers they're born
in 1949 1949 sort of 1946 to 1952
roughly that's what make it be mr.
Bourne who doesn't want history here
knows what that period of time was 1946
was clip it was after the Second World
War
right so person's life goes on what
happened to Bill of that really bad time
for everyone the depression the Great
Depression again but then following that
is like krei finally like everyone knew
after World War one actually this war is
not over okay
what won World War two is kind of a bit
of a misnomer world war two was just the
second act is yeah anyhow so that whole
period swine was pretty nasty
which is why following that around here
yeah this huge boot prints maybe users
but that's not what this is
that's this is a completely wrong time
period right what we're talking about
here again watch that jump I'll just
bring it back a little further and then
you can see it's just sort of go whoa
crazy right this isn't about foot
reception okay so but for that you boys
you're just so much like up this is poor
woman right a little bit because there's
just so much more difficult to control
how many children will be born but what
we do have control that has big effect
of this too did you notice that
okay so we talked about just the overall
trend we talked about I the fertility
rate and it's changed it how to
decreasing what else do you notice live
in the amplified or if we're going to
stay here because it's under this below
and then something just jump Ember
this change is what you're afraid to
discuss hmm now interestingly if I just
look at this portion of the graph at
this portion of the graph it's less that
Japan has changed then that we've
changed you know is that now I will
point out this is just this portion of
the guy so I have to take everything on
that Japan has kind of this steadier
rise right well do its monthly
everything's gonna be at least it's sort
of consistent whereas we've just kind of
flatlined for a while and then we have
this uptick right but we never catch up
to Japan and as you can see any other
last thing that you notice about this
[Music]
yep very real team yeah it's not like
that spreading out doesn't it it starts
to spread out okay now because not much
as y'all just I would dig too deep into
that but I wonder if you can think about
all the informations you have here and
let me delete quite limited at the
moment because somebody who does
economics help us work out what oh no
this is not the genes which worse when I
rode a big magnetic product to the hitch
so if you don't know what this is you
need to write it down it's very fun
GDP like it stands for worse so this did
product
yeah the reason why I put this out is
because this particular table is really
really important a little razor question
you guys in a minute
but even though this is like an
economics work it's really important
what's number one because it is a number
it's a it's a value if they are for sum
of money they're listed in US currency
let's just try to understand what it is
I'll do it in reverse product so this is
about something that a country produces
okay
some countries produce a lot of money
morning I'm so sorry you got afraid that
used to be altered throughout the county
I the last few decades was Australian
living on the ships back right in that a
lot of our product right a lot of what
the trick she produced was simply
agricultural at work okay and we
exported that in throughout the world
domestic where's the missing me to this
context domestic we meet within the
country we near the country so for a
country distances stuff that we per use
as opposed to stuff that we get is from
Austria and import ah gross yeah just
just the whole lot okay
so gross domestic product is something
that a country produces really big no
pup billions trillions of dollars but
this is a gross domestic product its
gross domestic product per capita which
is for each individual right so we take
that amount of money and we divide it by
your population
okay so you can see at the moment looks
really bad in area you'll notice that
number is significantly larger than what
it was just when I dragged it from
whatever was nothing to do with that
okay
what's the reason for that say again
number one biting
okay so we're producing we're getting
stuff out of the ground in tears fairly
and freaking themself are going to be
that's one factor another big factor
come on e Jewish people is that the
value of the dollar the value of the
dollar
changes pretty significantly over time
positive okay
so what do you call this that's a nice
information inflation all right I'm
pretty sure this is all fit adjusted for
inflation okay
that's why they're not they just kind of
skyrocket